a new study conducted by researchers in
arkansas which is where I get most my
studies from
suggest that our paths might have the
same love the hormone
that humans have it's called accede to
Posen and
let's look at some more info on binding
for humans oxy toes in or the love
hormone gets released when you're
cuddling are having an intimate
experience
researchers tested oxy toes in levels in
a dog
and ago after they hung out separately
then they let the two animals hang out
together for 15 minutes
after that they checked again the dogs
levels rose by
48 percent I which is about how much are
humans would change in a similar
situation
and a heavy even bigger number than that
the goats levels
went up 210 percent
Tino implying that the goat with him up
with the dog is this what gay marriage
was gonna lead to
no but this is certainly might be yes
ppl
not mean to they've been doing this for
thousands have your yeah
loving sheep and goats gonna feel they
have you know
may not get lonely Stephen Stills put it
best love the one you're with you
okay I fish tank playing and it wasn't
bad
yeah no I don't sorry that my bad about
it was a cheap shot
yeah recker you are you an animal guy
too I know Kelly is a big dog dog lady
on the Big Dawg I
I'm a big to an all rights person yes I
am yeah a.m.
so does this surprise you guys as animal
people I love my dog I am completely
confident that my dog loves me
well considering that we are evolved
from these creatures that doesn't
surprise me that we have similar hormone
I mean if you if a view believe in
evolution it makes perfect sense and
yeah and I think they're finding out
more and more now that
animals have a real inner emotional life
any is there a chimpanzee suing his
owners yup military if I could not cover
yeah I think really liked everything
it yeah I think every other week but
they're fine they having that they
haven't
inner emotional life which you know
really then goes to
argument for we should not be animal
testing we shouldn't ultimately be
eating these
creatures and I would be involved with
element IQ disease
I can't do I hated pet stores you see a
Moses time your thing in there
their Peter on those all bars on the
bottom there's like that in fact same
idea you watching a pace you're watching
a go crazy
like a prison a yeah it is absolutely at
but my thing about this which is I'm you
know science is finding all sorts of
amazing things about the brain and the
body and its
it's basically you know it's it's
discovering you know why we
box ito said why we connect why week you
know and the god thing you know the part
super brain that has that in it and it
all gets down reduced to cells and
chemicals and everything which
to me is depressing and the UK right
yeah shakespearian
you know sonnets and Baudelaire poetry I
want to believe in that and i think is a
away you know from you know being
Old Testament and then through rational
science important important but I think
you have to also give that
there is something else between us you
know yes it's out the toes and
and and what else though you know i
think thats exactly what I circle 10
times here so that part that part that's
between
science in the party bus that's very
human that wants to believe
that love is in some ox ito said or some
me to koreans if we were in Star Wars or
something you know like
ritual aspect I L I love comedy but
County isn't be making some big
king and my hormones have no idea at I
love it on a spiritual bomb cuz
the spiritual bond as I have a hunger
for certain things in my heart
and this energy comes in and starts to
fill the cup up I respond to that my why
I will
feedback as a starter Luke going because
I it Alabama level
I wanna be near I wanna feed from it
some more but I'm a healthy level
that's what all up is based on
recognizing something that made you feel
good
that I need filled a yeah yeah and I
think it's actually I think it's it is
about creating meaning in your life
yes it could be this chemical thing but
are mines these amazing
big frontal lobes are the things that
create meeting
and and that gives life its power and
and why we're here why we stick around
you know so
and science can't fuck with that you
know i mean it that is what happened
what we do with that
we've taken chemicals and made meaning
out a bit I mean look how amazing we are
you know sure that don't know dog love
each other but
may be there have any meaning around it
we need we would have a whole story a
rapid yeah
so it's picking up chemicals here we
ever yeah
complicated love all anything in our
alums Yahoo
be milder in the sheep yeah page yeah
a so going from from the chemicals to
to our brains how long until we put this
in pill form
because now it seems to me if we can
isolate this thing if you're good at one
thing around here
it's putting everything in pill form it
will have a little axe ito some pill
and your pop that with a by Agra and
there's your a rom-com
they never intended don't call it a lot
yeah
we got timing is government go on the
road
my well you know I think actually it if
they could
putting a pill for my it could save us
all because it is the ultimate love
child flower power moment I mean it is
that
everyone took ecstasy at the same time
on planet Earth
we've come across a roster something
like really amazing yeahh lol protester
up dust with without up to 80 said power
yet